So gametes produced from germ cells through
the process of meiosis end up with only
23 chromosomes, whereas the germ cells, their parent
cells, had 46 chromosomes. This is essential to
make sure that at fertilization, the sperm
and the egg combine 23 chromosomes a piece
to get 46 total, the complete genome necessary
to make a human. Now, this particular process
of DNA duplication with two rounds of cell division is
unique to meiosis, and only germ cells do it. All
other cells in your body divide through a process of
mitosis, where there's one DNA duplication event and only one
cell division. Now, take a look at the gametes here,
the sex cells produced as a product of meiosis. There
are no chromosome pairs anymore, every chromosome pair is split
up. And alleles ended up going to their own gamete.
This is called the law of segregation. This law
simply means that allele pairs separate during gamete formation.
This is something that's been known for a very
long time. In fact, Gregor Mendel, who you saw
in lesson one, was the first person to ever
identify this particular phenomenon. So based on what you
see here and what you now know about the
law of segregation, what is the probability that the dominant
lactase persistence allele, the plus symbol here, will
get past on, carried onto the next generation?